we are checking in with folks on the
phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's see
what is on our ease mind re what's going
on today you there re yeah I'm here
what's going on hey I asked you a
question this is a recently you you are
posted this clip of the the interview we
had with I think it was Stephen man so
he was talking about the the Kurdish
situation
yes and it's one that I personally find
to be very interesting overall but I
think there's several layers on and I
was curious what your opinion was
because you know and as it relates to
the sort of the context of you know
potential relationship with Israel I
think there are several layers I mean
first of all I think you know the the
Kurds aren't really sort of a monolithic
group right so I mean the Iraqi Kurds
that you have the Turkish Kurds to sort
of have a little bit more antipathy
towards the West do there do the West in
support of the Turkish government which
is committed atrocities and then you
have like the Iranian Kurds which are a
little bit more I think so I guess some
would say subdued in the sense that that
they're they haven't been as active and
I think part of that is just you know
the situation you know just the
geopolitical situation part of that so
they sort of have more of a shared
history with other Iranian groups like
the Persians which they don't really
identify as much with the Arabs and the
Turks but I think as it relates to
you're talking about sort of the Arab
and Middle Eastern leaders concerned
that this was some sort of Israeli plot
and obviously there's you know there's
no shortage of that type of rhetoric
coming from those leaders you know
whether it's talking about how the
Mossad is planning sharks in the water
or you know clouds that are you know
causing traps in the Middle East
but I think on the other side of that
equation when you talk about
specifically about people like net Yahoo
or even Ayelet shaked or all these poor
far even to the right of and even I
would say transcending beyond Israeli
politics someone like John Bolton I
think there is it's sort of a leap to
say that there may
their main driver for why they want to
see independent Kurdish state has to do
with the fact that they really they
really care about the self-determination
of Kurds I think they there is an aspect
of viewing the Kurds as sort of a
geopolitical sort of asset that could
potentially be used to as leverage
against other adversaries they have in
common so I think that that's something
but I mean there's no doubt there's
plenty of Israelis and Americans
conservative whatnot that they just uh
you know they sympathize with the plight
of them but I think they're that aspect
is not that's what I'm talking about
with those specific sort of people that
I mentioned that tend to be hawkish is
not an insignificant one I don't know
what your what your thoughts are on that
yeah I agree I mean with any of these
complex geopolitical issues there's not
going to be when you have complex
intersecting interests you're not going
to have one element that is the one that
will ultimately lead to the path on
which a population will be in terms of
how its perceived and sort of works with
other interests so everything you're
mentioning is true the
israeli-palestinian conflict is an
element the idea of the Kurds as a
moderating influence in a region that
many would argue but would would benefit
from that moderation is a factor what
appeals to john bolton about an
independent Kurdish state would be very
different than potentially what if he
appeals to a right-wing Israeli or what
appeals to a left-wing Israeli or how it
relates to Iran I think you're
absolutely right I mean these are
complex issues and having the most
nuanced possible understanding puts us
in the best position to make good
decisions I mean even just even the
Turkish Kurds like the PKK is sort of
the communist girls that defined the
government from what I know they
actually used to fight alongside the PLO
and Lebanon against the Israeli forces
so it's really it's a really
multi-faceted issue from different you
know from different sites that it's kind
of it yeah absolutely all right Ari
great to hear from you thanks for the
call six one seven eight three zero
4750 is the number